Я вважаю, що освіта
відіграє величезну роль,
і я вважаю, що це тому, що освіта
є засобом вирішення деяких найбільш
фундаментальних питань нашого часу, коли
ви думаєте про
громадянську ідентичність, коли ви думаєте про
розвиток людини, про яку ви повинні
думати  це таким чином, як
ми надаємо базову
освіту,
яку повинні мати молоді люди
для навчання протягом усього життя та
орієнтації, які хочуть
вчитися, поки живуть, тож мова йде не лише
про початкову освіту, а про
початкову середню вищу, це про
навчання впродовж усього життя, що навіть коли вам
виповнилося 70 років, ви продовжуєте
прагнути продовжувати пізнавати
світ,
кожна людина у світі повинна
мати
доступ до освіти в
і
та адаптована як досвід навчання протягом усього життя
та насолоджуватися нею
сьогодні
Україна бореться за глобальні цінності,
ми маємо численні виклики,
але ми продовжуватимемо всі наші реформи
навіть у цей час війни
у ​​світі освіти  форум нас
усіх підбадьорила
ідея будувати вперед разом
сильніше сміливіше краще
в україні
ми зробимо все це
наступного року я сподіваюся говорити про
наш успіх у відновленні української
освіти
завдяки нашим власним зусиллям
і щедрій допомозі наших
міжнародних друзів
роль вчителя та
присутність у
класі соціальний контакт
є ключовим
питанням процесу навчання,
звичайно, ми не можемо використовувати технології, але
технології самі по собі не змінять
якість і не зменшать
нерівність нашої освіти, якщо ми не
інвестуємо та не визнаємо  роль
вчителів
у наших
освітніх системах. У вас є вчителі,
які повертаються до керівників своїх шкіл і
говорять, що ви знаєте, під час цієї пандемії я
зрозумів, що найважливіше
не бути чудовим інструктором, а
стати хорошим тренером, хорошим наставником,
оцінювач добре, ви знаєте, навіть соціальні
працівники психологи, тож
ці ролі змінюються, і тому
в класі потрібно ча  Нам
потрібно змінити конфігурацію простору,
людей, час,
технології та стосунки по-
новому, ось що насправді
означає зникнення
, про що зникає класна кімната, справа не в тому, щоб ви знали, що
освіта зникне, чи
взаємодія між учнями,
учнем і  педагога, але це те, що
їхні стосунки змінять
навчання та викладання
відбувається мультимодальним способом прямо зараз
навчання та викладання відбувається через
різні канали, нам просто потрібно
зрозуміти,
як ці канали працюють, для
чого вони корисні, і як ми можемо
використати їх силу  канали на
користь кращого навчання
та більшої справедливості в наших школах
і освітніх системах,
тому я справді сподіваюся, що ми розробимо
наші цифрові освітні платформи як
стійку відповідь,
щоб запобігти майбутнім збоям,
але, звичайно, в класі
та школі залишаються ядром нашої
освітня програма
нікарагуа
um рівень абсолютної
залежності питання екстрем
Бідність нездатність зробити людей значущими для
себе та суспільства
досягається лише через освіту
я загалом дивлюся на
освіту
як про світло,
оскільки у світі
багато світла,
але
є багато темряви,
за винятком того, що ми бачимо
темряву як загрозу  до
світла легше забути про загрозу цієї
темряви,
а для того, щоб увесь світ був
яскраво освітлений, світло має
розширитися й охопити земну кулю,
і це справжня освіта,
я вважаю, що у нас найкращий час,
щоб бути вчителем
тому що сьогодні це щось на кшталт революції,
комітет дав нам
можливість побачити, що ми переживаємо
цей час, коли
ми повинні думати
по-іншому,
тому ми дійсно пишаємося нашими вчителями,
і я думаю, що
це час, коли люди можуть подумати
про те, щоб стати  вчитель, це найкраще
місце,
де ми можемо бути у світі освіти,
хм, тому що ми
торкаємось життя наших студентів, громадян у
всьому світі,
але зворотна сторона цього:  Ви знаєте, що
освіта – це не лише
процес обміну педагогічними знаннями, це соціальний
процес, а
також те, що студенти грають
разом,
відвідують один одного, ви знаєте фізично
тощо
, дуже важливо у формуванні
молодих людей у ​​майбутньому, ви отримуєте
подвійна освіта, я маю на увазі змішану
освіту
в певному відсотковому співвідношенні,
і це нормально, поки у вас є
діти, які
працюють разом, тому що вони вчаться
разом і їм потрібно бути
разом. Неможливо
зникнути класи,
тому що
освіта є соціальною
діяльністю, і вам потрібно  нехай діти навчаються
разом,
і якщо ви думаєте про зникнення
класних кімнат, це призведе
до
психічних проблем,
психічні проблеми,
ізоляція
може
погіршити ситуацію,
вони не повинні замінювати класні кімнати,
тому що класні кімнати – це більше, ніж місця для
навчання та викладання, але це
також соціальні місця для дітей,
існують центри  де про дітей
піклуються, там діти формують
партнерство  або вони створюють дружбу,
і це місце, де вони справді
ростуть зі своїми
однолітками. Шлях вперед, як ви знаєте, випливає з того
факту, що
освіта
є серцевиною наших можливостей,
ви знаєте, що наші життєві вибори, як
ви знаєте, загалом тяжітимуть
навколо освіти  інвестиції,
які ми робимо, та
освітня освіта, яку ми надаємо нашим
людям,
я думаю, що цікавість є
центральною частиною нашої освіти,
не лише, можливо, освіти, але й нашого
досвіду у світі,
тому
цікавість
стимулює
всіх нас
чогось навчитися,
щоб залишити щось для досвіду
випробувати щось,
тож якщо
ви вилучите справжню цікавість
із навчання,
то, ймовірно, це буде
порожнім,
правда,
найважливіше –
отримати
хороших вчителів,
навчених вчителів,
вчителів,
які
матимуть
соціальну та фінансову захищеність
, щоб вони могли
повністю присвятити
себе своїй
роботі  ми також зіткнулися з цією проблемою в
пакистані,
і
ми
склали план, щоб дати їм
дати th  Вчителі мають стимули,
тож вони мають
обрати цю професію,
і
ми
це зробимо,
і я думаю, що ситуація в Пакистані
покращиться, безумовно,
освітня реформа є хорошою,
особливо для людей
із середнім рівнем доходу
та загрозою з
низьким рівнем
доходів, освітнім
потребам слід приділяти пріоритет,
тому  що ми покращуємо життя
наших громадян у будь-якій країні світу
, щоб суспільство та
населення стали конкурентоспроможними в
мінливому середовищі,
щоб будь-яке суспільство розвивалося
та розвивалося правильним шляхом,
громадянам потрібно
навчати  вирішувати багато суспільних проблем
проблеми розвитку
з освіченим суспільством буде в змозі
досягти цінностей норм
і забезпечити, щоб сектор не тільки
освітній сектор суспільство
досягало успіхів у розвитку в усіх напрямках
дистанційна освіта
є відповіддю,
але також може дистанційна
освіта  відповідати на
всі витрати, необхідні
для
запровадження технології, необхідної
для надання освіти  ми багато дізналися
про використання технологій, ми знаємо, що
це корисно, але це не
панацея, це не рішення,
технологія не є чимось, що
замінює особистий
контакт, особисте навчання та навчання віч-
на-віч.  і навчання,
і тим не менше це корисно,
наприклад, для охоплення вчителів, жодна
технологія не може використовуватися для
підтримки вчителів і
надання матеріалів,
створення груп і обговорення тощо, а
також технологія може бути використана для охоплення
учнів ні, і це те, що
було доведено  бути дуже корисним,
щоб мати можливість використовувати технологію, коли
учні не ходять до школи, щоб мати
змогу зв’язатися з ними, тому ми повинні підтримувати
вчителів матеріалами та дуже
структурованою педагогікою, якої вони можуть
дотримуватися та де вони можуть злитися зі
своїми навичками
цікавість, ймовірно, лежить в основі
освіти,
тому
що саме так ми відкриваємо речі,
і коли ми виростаємо, ти маєш
продовжувати відкривати своє оточення  залізні
соціальні відносини тощо, а
системі освіти потрібно розвивати
цікавість до дітей та молоді,
щоб вони могли приймати виклики та
намагатися просувати кордони знань,
і я вважаю, що це надзвичайно
важливо, і
ми повинні
спробувати  якомога більше, щоб уникнути
ситуації, коли ми просто хочемо обмежити
наших дітей і молодь системою освіти,
нам просто потрібно зробити їх
трохи сміливішими, щоб ставити запитання
, намагатися
досліджувати, цікавитися
новими речами та досвідом тощо
так,
вони добре передбачають світ,
я думаю, що
це найактуальніші проблеми, які якимось чином
відповідають потребам майбутнього
покоління в умовах
такого невизначеного світу,
що стає все важче й важче
передбачити, що станеться, і
я думаю, що людство стає все більш
виклик з точки зору
підготовки, які типи навичок, який
тип поведінки, які типи ставлення
можуть привести до більш
стійкого чи
більш
мирного
світу  Я вважаю, що
основним викликом є ​​підготовка майбутнього покоління до такого невизначеного майбутнього